le gouvernement aussi annoncé en fin de
semaine la mise sur pied d'une
plateforme de mise en valeur des
entreprises québécoises
ça s'appelle le panier bleus on en parle
tout de suite avec alain dumas directeur
général de l'organisme à but non
lucratif le panier bleus bonsoir
monsieur dumas bonjour monsieur fillion
alors dites-nous c'est quoi l'intention
du site le panier bleus bon en fait
l'intention du site c'est vraiment de
trouver un endroit de ralliement pour
marie autant les détaillants et les
consommateurs parce que comme vous le
savez dans le commerce de détail d'une
crise majeure en ce moment avec avec la
crise que l'on vit et le site se veut
une solution pour les consommateurs de
retrouver les commerçants locaux au
pouvoir les encourager pour traverser
cette crise c'est comme un gros bottin
où il est facile de trouver ce qu'on
cherche parmi des des entrepreneurs des
entreprises et commerces locaux
québécois oui mais en fait c'est oui ce
jeudi reste un beau texte un bottin qui
vont gérer ce se développer avec le
temps évolué dont je te bottin qui va
jouir des technologies qu'on a comme par
exemple la géolocalisation et on va
ajouter des fonctionnalités on a un plan
de déploiement et de développement pour
les dix sept douze prochaines semaines
justement pour ajouter des fonctions
fonctionnalités
là vous dites 10 à 12 semaines est ce
que c'est une initiative qui est
temporaire juste durant la crise de la
kfw 19 où vous voulez garder sans suite
en fait l'idée en ce moment on a on a
pensé un temps minimal de 1 pour
maintenir ce site là je vous avoue que
là l'objectif aussi c'est de voir si un
mouvement aussi puissant au niveau de la
chaleur car pour justifier la
maintenance d'un tel d'un tel site est
aussi de voir sur pour moyen de faire
évoluer cette là dans le futur pour
encore mieux répondre autant aux
commerçants et aux consommateurs
le mouvement pour l'achat local est-ce
qu'on se sent est ce que vous le sentez
oui on le sent
et sérieusement on le sentait vous êtes
vous même dans les médias sociaux c'est
à discuter beaucoup dans les médias
sociaux et les gens peinaient à trouver
comment aider leurs commerçants parce
que comme vous le savez les sites de
type google les engins de recherche
souvent sont basées sur du référencement
qui beaucoup le poids en fait
d'utilisation d'un site donc quand vous
cherchez dans gougaud souvent vous vous
retrouvez tout le temps avec les mêmes
enseignes avec l'idée de faire un
annuaire qui est démocratique en
parenthèse c'est de pouvoir mettre
ensemble l'entièreté des commerçants
est-ce que ce site pourrait devenir
transactionnel écouter c il y aurait une
possibilité dans la mesure où on verrait
qu'un mouvement occitan qui s'intensifie
qui durent dans le temps donc c'est pas
c'est pas nécessairement ajouter du
revers de la main
mais à ce moment ci c'est vraiment pas
l'émission l'âme
la mission du site donc élise que vous
avez décrit jusqu'à maintenant mais
l'intention derrière le site quand même
le gouvernement du québec qui est
derrière lo benel oui et donc est ce que
est ce que le fait que ce soit le
gouvernement qui viennent favoriser nos
produits favoriser nos entreprises
est-ce qu'il peut y avoir un enjeu de
respect des accords de libre échange que
le canada a conclu
non je crois pas parce que c'est pas une
barrière à l'entrée en fait c'est
seulement une façon différente d'avoir
accès aux marchands parce que ces
marchands lieu normalement vous pouvez
les retrouver autrement vous pouvez
retrouver sur le fait sur facebook par
exemple souvent ayons des pages facebook
et autres moi par exemple il ya un
restaurant proche chez moi et j'ai
appris par facebook qui faisait du t4 je
suis à lille l'encourager en achetant du
tkc jusque avec un site comme le plein
le panier bleus mais à ce moment là ça
va être plus facile pour les
consommateurs de retrouver leur offre
locale puis d'encourager les petits
commerçants du coin on comprend que ce
n'est pas un site de produits fabriqués
au québec mais des entreprises du québec
nombre des entreprises qui importent des
produits d'ailleurs se retrouve aussi
sur cette plateforme
oui ça il y avait une raison pour se
sauver moi je viens du commerce de
détail alimentaire
comment ces détails alimentant la chance
d'avoir un organisme de certification
qui est aliments du québec qui garantit
par exemple la provenance des produits
je voudrais dans le non alimentaire
c'est assez complexe au niveau de la
quincaillerie blé la provenance n'est
pas toujours très clair
et l'autre chose qu'on voulait pas
défavorisé par exemple le petit
commerçant les petite quincaillerie du
coin qui elle vend des produits qu'ils
ne proviennent pas nécessairement du
québec mais c'est parce que en
approvisionnement et de produits qui
viennent de l'extérieur du québec et on
veut quand même encouragé ce commerçant
la survie va travailler pour bien des
gens pour ne pas dire pour la plupart
des gens c'est souvent le prion qui
compte c'est portefaix qui compte
d'abord et avant tout est ce que le
panier bleus va offrir des meilleurs
prix pour l'instant ce qu'on va offrir
ça en fait c'est les commerçants qui
décide des prix jeu très juste faire une
parenthèse par rapport à le judo boxe
une légende urbaine les libr prix il
savait souvent on fait des comparaisons
avec des places de marché avec des
produits comparables parce que bien
entendu il faut choisir des produits
comparables
et on se rend compte à l'évidence que
les places de marché même
internationales ne sont pas aussi peu
cher que ça une valeur aux produits qui
est perçu la seule chose c'est que vous
retrouvez souvent par exemple des
reproductions ou des produits moins
bonne qualité qu'ils vendent à des prix
plus bas mais pour un produit comparable
souvent nos marchands sont quand même
assez compétitifs il ya d'autres
initiatives qui ont été lancées il y en
a un qui s'appelle solutions locales
mazzone québec
j'achète bleus en quoi toutes ces
initiatives viennent véritablement
faciliter l'achat local
mais en fait c'est un peu le but de
lancer le panier bleus c'est que nous on
joue au 11 juin site fédérateur c'est
vrai que même ces initiatives là on veut
les amener sur notre chapeau en quelque
part pour que le consommateur
choisissent par quelle porte il veut
passer l'important je crois ce moment à
si c'est pas de regarder si voyons des
copies de même solution des choses comme
ça c'est vraiment de regarder comment
ensemble on peut attirer le plus
possible consommateurs à faire un
mouvement social et d'acheter dans les
commerces
à l'est du mans merci beaucoup et
surtout bonne chance
merci merci à warri